hey some people lives here and I just
wanted to do a video just to say a
massive thank you for your love and
support you know what I'm so excited
because yesterday I just saw that we hit
on this channel 1 million views which is
just incredible and I'm so humbled and I
never expected this channel to become so
awesome and popular with such fantastic
people such fantastic comments and so
much love I started this channel a few
years ago and I was literally just doing
it for a few people that were asking hey
you asking me questions I just say well
video the answer and you can watch it
and then we just grew this organic
following I'm getting people approached
me now saying hey Samuel can you can we
advertise on your channel and YouTube
have even contacted me you know what
there's never gonna be a day when over
and adverts on this channel because I
don't plan on making money off youtube
because I believe you reap what you sow
and I just want to just give away as
much as I possibly can for free just
because I'm on a mission to help as many
people become financially free as
possible and what goes around comes
around so there's never gonna be any
adverts on this channel despite us now
hitting a million views and I love you
guys so much thank you very very much
for watching I wish you a very Merry
Christmas although this is not the end
of the year for my videos we've got some
incredible ones coming up my financial
freedom challenge is going to be coming
out on Boxing Day got some absolutely
kick-ass videos and we're just getting
started next year we're moving to a gear
5 baby so guys love you so much thank
you for watching this and peace out see
you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
you